cette image résume il arrête ton rapport
aux femmes c'est mon cher franck tu sais
mon cher franck tu sais à quel point je
t'aime je me sommes amis nous sommes
collègues je voudrais te dire avant que
tu ne me parle plus jamais de toute ta
vie tu as été un mec qui a beaucoup
compté pour moi et nous les deux sur
franck et c'est pas des fautes aussi des
diapositives
c'est pas un 12 sur franck je crois que
je vais quitter le studio
je pense que tu as été un mec formidable
je sais que tu va m'en vouloir pendant
des années si je ramène des trucs à la
france inter qui nous regardent
regardez ça vous n'en reviendrez pas
mélanie remblin gérons plan
[Applaudissements]
ouais
gad elmaleh ou fait est honteux filets
bleus nous a menés 4 expresso is all
manière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jade
on m'a dit smoking obligatoire massaly
tu viens faire le plus grand cadeau
sequana gagné avec qui tu joues toi
c'est pas croyable va passer de l'autre
côté les amis on a beaucoup d'os a
envoyé j'ai pas envie de faire trop de
commentaires avant d'envoyer cette image
d'elie semoun s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai quasiment pas changé a changé de
costume
j'aimerais retirer ce que j'ai dit les
amis / lesure sur sur la tenue de
philippe lellouche parce que c'est un
peu mauvaise langue c'est vrai qu'il n'a
pas toujours manqué de goût est pardon
pardon c'est vrai voilà philippe louges
récemment la fashion week
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
kitty higgins et joe dassin cet attentat
ça s'appelait elle s'appelle stéphanie
s'est petit à virer lauréat à brno rixe
je vous tiendrai cette tentative odieuse
de gad elmaleh
voilà ah oui c'est d'y danser du
discrédit permanent cette attaque basse
j'irai même à dire c'est de l'anti c'est
mérité